Chacha what are you doing home I thought
you had a date with
Dennis not till
10 anyway Rosie um I know you're upset
because I forgot our anniversary but I'm
just hoping that this will make up for
it oh so sweet since paper is the
traditional first anniversary gift oh
bounty
now I can cross it off my
list happy anniversary Rose
bu don't wait
up is it
safe my husband's gone but I would not
say that it is safe my little cup of CR
de Kaka
wates Rosie can I have some
cash
Jennifer Love hu what the hell's going
on
here what can I say CH the Heart Wants
What It Wants but you and Gardner where
in love we want to get
married well I guess it's clear I'm the
only one in this relationship who values
the sanctity of marriage come on
Fernando pissed honey you don't know the
meaning of that word if you'll remember
the last time we left the interesting
story I had three different people dying
to marry me including a nine-time
Wimbledon singles
champion and I left them all behind to
be with the man I love and then it turns
out the bastard's married Stan is
married can you believe that I had three
different people dying to marry me
including a six time Wimbledon singles
Champion oh shut your trap
butterfly who the hell are you listen
Bozo the
Clown you're bringing us down if it was
meant to be with this man it was meant
to be hey who asked you to pop your head
out of your conch shell if I want advice
I'm not going to ask for it from a
cigarette slinging tray carrying mint
Wrangler you better watch your mail
get you back
next I like you why don't you come work
for me
okay and although it was 10 years before
Stan and I officially hooked up Rosario
and I have been together ever
since damn it my story sucks too I can't
totally explain it Karen but it's like
Rosario's all around me she's in me and
then she's out of
me she's in me and then she's out of me
it's like our wedding night all over
again is she happy does she like
cleaning
Heaven she says it's bigger than she
thought but they do let her take home
leftover chicken and the
recyclables does she have a message for
me she does
oh this is interesting Rosario says
you're going to find love again that's
crap what did she break into God's
Liquor
Cabinet um this is coming from a
disembodied ghost so kind of think it's
real she doesn't know what she's talking
about uh oh she did not like
that why what' she
say Rosario I'm not going to tell her
that well just tell me she says you're
going to get mad I'm not going to get me
out she says you're a quitter she says
you should put on that perfume and get
your Rich pampered ass back out
there she is not allowed to talk to me
that
way even though she is dead she's
fired what what are you doing she's
coming through she's taking
over I'm losing
myself
well there are a few things I'd like to
say to you
too if you quit on love you're a fool
what the hell know that love only
that swall and pass through your diges
TR why do you think I but stand outside
the door gloves on and that means
there's someone for
you Rosie
do you really think so I do and I won't
give up on
love I love you Mommy I love you too
Mommy I miss those
lips she's coming she's
coming she's
oh no Rosie
wait Rosie Rosario what does Jack's
father do make people feel bad about who
they
are this is no time to be fooling around
Karen she's
right Rosario you'll go in first I need
some water again what are you snacking
on a Salt Lick when I'm not
looking look Jack There Goes My World
there goes my everything you stopped
worrying she's just a maid just a
maid that's like saying that Pras are
just shoes or vodka is just a morning
beverage Karen please The Dramatics
don't you understand how
she
okay I am going to tell you something
that
I've never told
anyone Rosario is my
mother she is not your mother all right
she's not my
mother but sweet nectar of the Gods
nobody gets the Mero out of my nylons
like that little
plant well she runs the entire house she
she alphabetizes my medicine cabinets
she knows the ins and
out she's my
friend
she is not your
friend my God she
is
Wow real
feelings are you
okay look Karen just leave everything to
me I promise nothing will go wrong okay
okay I'll see Mr and Mrs McFarland
now
oh
yes I remember him
well how could you not know he worked
for the ins don't they teach you
anything at homo
school so what kind of music does your
uh husband like well when he's doing but
robics he likes in
sync but for the spinning class he
prefers the oldies you know Frankie Goes
to Hollywood relax stop doing that
relax and and where did you two meet H
let me guess it was Boy bar I don't know
what you're talking about there was a
blind date and we went to
Arby's okay let's stop pretending I've
gotten farther with your husband than
you have I hope your bags are packed cuz
you're going back to El Salvador oh my
God honey they're sending her
back no they're not
no one's going
anywhere how dare you imply our marriage
is a sham uh you're
gay what a guy sleeps with guys and
immediately he's pegged as
gay let me tell you a little something
about the day I met
Rosario I looked over the top of those
half glasses into those big brown eyes
and I knew from that moment love had
found Jack McFarland oh my
cha Rosario my love my life my all I
Adore You You Had Me At
[Applause]
Ola good
Lord you know you shouldn't look but
there is a certain morbid Fascination
isn't there
sweetie I believe this is
yours now I've seen people desperate to
be an American but that is desperate to
be an
American fine you pass see you in 6
months we never
met we won oh H you were magnificent and
the light is back in my life oh honey
you know it's funny how sometimes you
just don't realize how much you might
miss something until it's almost gone
which reminds me I've got a Chanel suit
at the dry cleaners and boy did I miss
it come on hey close in an hour move it
or lose
it